now let's consider the case where an
object is undergoing circular motion but
in this motion let's again introduce our
polar coordinate system our hat and beta
hat we now want to consider the case
where d theta/dt is not constant and
what does that mean
that means that if d theta/dt is
positive for instance the object is
speeding up in this direction or if d
theta/dt is negative the object is
slowing down in this direction that's
one type of case so in this instant we
always know that there's a radial
component at any instant given by minus
R D theta DT squared but because it's
speeding up and slowing down there is
now a non zero tangential component to
the acceleration and let's see where
that comes from so again if we write our
velocity vector as our D theta DT theta
hat this is the product of two terms and
because it's a product of two terms we
need the product rule from calculus and
when we take a derivative so the
derivative will be the derivative of the
first term times the second term plus
the first term times the derivative of
the second term
now we've already analyzed this piece
and this was precisely - our D theta DT
quantity squared R hat that was the
always the non zero ten radial
acceleration but now let's analyze this
piece separately R for our circular
motion is a constant so it's only D
theta DT that is no longer constant so
we simply take a second derivative and
so we get R times d squared theta DT
squared theta hat
and that is our acceleration notice that
it has two components we'll write the
first component a theta that's its
tangential component theta hat plus the
radial component a R that's again the
component and because this is a vector R
hat where the a theta is now the second
derivative of D theta squared DT squared
and just to remind you that a R is minus
AR D theta DT squared so when d squared
theta DT squared is positive it means D
theta DT is increasing and so if this
object is going in this clockwise
direction we call that speeding up in a
similar fashion it's easy to understand
that when d squared theta DT squared is
negative then D theta DT is decreasing
and so it can be slowing down or if it
slows down and stops you can start to
move in the other direction so again the
acceleration has two components a
tangential component and that depends on
the type of circular motion we're
talking about whether d theta DT is
constant or not it always has a nonzero
inward radial component given by Muk the
component minus R D theta T squared
regardless of whether it's speeding up
or slowing down